avant coville nous avions 30 magasins
comme celui-ci et du jour au lendemain
avec le confinement les difficultés
financières déjà présentes deviennent
trop lourde à porter pour l'eau les
l'entreprise montréalaise de vêtements
de sport se met à l'abri de ses
créanciers et se restructure
complètement
il ne reste aujourd'hui que quatre
boutiques en amérique du nord
mais les affaires vont mieux nos
beaucoup beaucoup moins de dépenses donc
le service aussi de vente en ligne a
explosé nos produits c'est des produits
qui sont très en amont présentement sous
ta fabiola la maison à faire des
activités extérieures
les grandes bannières avec de nombreux
magasins et leurs coûts fixes sortent
péniblement de la pandémie
parmi les fermetures l'enseigne le
château avec ses 123 succursales et 1400
travailleurs l'industrie du vêtement
montréal troisième pole sur le continent
après los angeles et new york demeure
malgré tout résigne à la diversification
de l'approvisionnement par exemple
l'accélération de la performance
numérique ça nous a permis de
s'améliorer de devenir plus compétitifs
le propriétaire de lula jean a déménagé
sa production de l'asie au mexique pour
se différencier et offrir un donneur
plus éco responsable on a dû vraiment se
recycler rapidement se réinventer une
chose qu'on a fait ce qu'on a renforcé
notre présence en ligne lagence jlg qui
agit comme intermédiaire entre
manufacturiers et détaillants a observé
une autre tendance ce que nous on a vu
surtout dans nos boutiques indépendantes
au québec c'est que beaucoup de gens qui
ont commencé à faire des stéroïdes et
live facebook
instagram de vendre en ligne à tout les
types de clients ce jeu là venez paris à
capuchon en cinq couleurs
il ya des femmes sont de 50 ans qui
magasinaient pas nécessairement en ligne
avant la cage vide
l'agencé a tout de même perdu 30% de son
chiffre d'affaires certaines marques
étrangères ont cessé de distribuer au
canada et des clients à l'aube de la
retraite ont préféré mettre les clés
supporte l'industrie plus fragiles à
voir rester encore pour la prochaine
année
évidemment avec la part des 1000 le
télétravail il ya moins de demandes pour
les complet comment était votre année
c'était une année vraiment difficile
quand vous saviez pas seulement le
télétravail ya plus de mariage il ya
plus de restaurant il ya plus de parties
en cinq ans j'ai rendu avait réussi à
ouvrir cinq magasins dans le grand
montréal
trois ont dû être fermées heureusement
on a fait un petit virage vers les
masques qui a sauvé un petit peu la
business parce qu'on a on était capable
de payer les loyers
la production de ces vêtements lassé des
blues d'isolation vêtements peerless a
dû temporairement fabriquer des
équipements de protection pour les
travailleurs de la santé afin de
poursuivre ses opérations
bien loin des complets calvin klein et
tommy hilfiger qu'elle confectionne
normalement graduellement les ventes
dhabi ont repris
très faible niveau seulement la moitié
des 1000 employés sont donc à l' ouvrage
on a quand même adapter notre produit
aussi à la nouvelle réalité du marché on
a de plus en plus des vêtements qui sont
souples des vêtements qui sont un peu
plus d construit son voeu avec un look
un peu plus fort les vêtements seront
toujours indispensable mais beaucoup
auront probablement découvert les vertus
du coton ouaté et de son confort il si
mathieu radio canada montréal